Russia Russia and a bit more Russia such
has been the barrage of international
news it's Putin's hordes invaded Ukraine
in February 2022. the Ukrainian War has
garnered virtually all media and
political attention internationally and
understandably so you could say that it
stands to reason that the war in Ukraine
has overshadowed everything else
including other tragic events as well
for example you remember these images
from 2021
indeed August 2021 with the withdrawal
of the last U.S troops Afghanistan fell
back into the hands of Islamic
fundamentalism Afghanistan fell back
under the thumb of the Taliban and I
know what many of you are going to say
but hang on Josh didn't you already tell
us this story well yes it's true in 2021
here on visualpolitik WE published a
Trilogy telling you why the Taliban was
so successful and what their comeback
could mean if you didn't see those three
videos look in the description after
almost two years of Taliban government
we wanted to make a new video to tell
you how the new government is doing and
what exactly turn to Power of the
Taliban has meant for the country
although I think that with news
headlines like this you can already
guess where we're going Afghan children
starving to death as hunger rapidly
spreading hunger poverty continue to
stalk desperate Afghans a lack of
funding batter Afghanistan's troubled
economy leading to increased poverty
indeed Afghanistan is going through one
of its worst crises of all time and
humanitarian Aid well it simply does not
arrive like it did before the Taliban
but not only that the destruction of
practically all individual freedoms
having turned this country back into a
Haven for radical groups and their
particular way of governing think
despotic and anachronistic is making
Afghanistan a leading Contender for
becoming the worst country in the world
but visual politic viewers how did the
Taliban get to this point how exactly
are they ruling Afghanistan is the
government as disastrous as many say it
is or are they learning to run the
country who is trying to win favor with
the Taliban today well in this video
we're going to answer all these
questions and I can already tell you
that many of the answers are sure to
surprise you or maybe not anyway let's
get started
[Music]
zero
I'm certain many if not most of you
think that the Taliban are nothing more
than a bunch of power hungry loonies and
in a way that might be so but do you
know where they came from does the word
mean anything to you well the Taliban
started out as mujahideen that is
strictly speaking Islamic Fighters
practicing Jihad typically however when
we hear about mujahideen the vast
majority automatically think of those
U.S backed Afghans who fought against
the Soviet Union when it invaded
Afghanistan in 1979 as might be expected
after the Soviet withdrawal the
mujahideen started a kind of civil war
between 1992 and 1996. out of that
conflict were born the Taliban who by
the way won the war and so the first
Taliban government was born in 1996.
this first Taliban government has been
considered one of the most brutal in
recent history human rights were
constantly disregarded public executions
on soccer fields the stoning of women
for adultery and inhumane punishments
for simply showing any part of the
female body not surprisingly any
individual rights or freedoms for women
were wiped off the map they were
deprived of access to education of
having a job and even of being able to
move around unless it was with a man in
their Circle a total hell it was a
regime so brutal that it was recognized
by only three countries in the world
Pakistan Saudi Arabia and the United
Arab Emirates the regime ended up
falling five years after taking power as
it turns out it did not fall due to any
internal social Uprising but because of
Uncle Sam's intervention as you all know
after the 9 11 attacks the United States
targeted the Taliban for having made
Afghanistan a safe space for terrorist
groups such as bin Laden's Al-Qaeda
Washington demanded the surrender of the
al-Qaeda leaders and when the Taliban
refused in October of that same year
Umesh groups invaded the country the
first Taliban government was history
nevertheless as the saying goes bad
pennies have a way of showing up and
that is exactly what happened with the
Taliban despite the overwhelming control
of the United States during the initial
years in 2005 the Taliban began to
regroup and in 2006 they started to
develop operations of a certain
magnitude against the U.S troops
thereafter with the support of the
Pakistani government the presence and
influence of the Taliban gradually
spread throughout most of the country
what's more thanks to the high revenues
derived from the opium trade the Taliban
managed to become the best financed
armed and organized Insurgency group the
perfect Insurgency and a nightmare for
Washington stiff Taliban resistance and
little progress by either the government
or the Afghan military itself LED then
president Donald Trump to make a
decision that made International
headlines in 2020 check it out Afghan
conflict U.S and Taliban signed deal to
end 18-year War indeed without the
involvement of the Afghan government
Trump struck a deal with the Taliban he
promised to withdraw all U.S troops by
the summer of 2021. in return the
Taliban were to commit that Afghanistan
would not become a nest of international
terrorist groups that could threaten the
United States and its allies the second
Taliban government in Afghanistan was
already underway and so that's exactly
what happened in 2021 much more quickly
than anyone would have predicted after
the departure of the U.S troops the
Afghan Army virtually fell apart and the
Taliban retook Kabul since then the
country has disappeared from the
mainstream media but what has actually
been happening since then and what does
the new Afghanistan of the Taliban look
like well let's take a look
conversion
[Music]
let's be honest anyone with a little
Common Sense knew that the Taliban were
going to follow a more or less similar
course to that of their first government
it is true that this time they have
tried to show themselves as somewhat
more moderate but the data is the data
and the reality is that with this
Taliban Afghanistan has once again
become a hell on Earth although for some
more than others Afghanistan Taliban ban
women from universities amid
condemnation Taliban prohibit Afghan
women from working with the United
Nations exactly dear visual politic
Community the Taliban have done just
what we all expected they have once
again taken away practically all women's
rights and freedoms with the stroke of a
pen women cannot study in universities
nor can teenage girls attend high
schools nor can they work in ngos or
United Nations agencies and not only
that in the companies in which they are
allowed to work which are becoming fewer
and fewer they can only do so if they
are completely separated from men and
naturally if they do not comply with the
strict dress code they can expect the
worst all of this courtesy of the
re-established ministry for the
propagation of virtue and the prevention
of Vice which is what the Taliban have
put in place of the ministry of women's
Affairs that had been in place until
they came along and that's not the end
of it
along with the women the tajiks who are
the most critical voices against the
Taliban and the second largest ethnic
group in the country after the passions
the group to which by the way most of
the Taliban belong are also being
harshly repressed raids forced searches
arbitrary arrests beatings and
disappearings as well as extrajudicial
killings have terrorized tajiks and
virtually anyone who dares to criticize
the Taliban regime of course as you can
imagine freedom of expression is
conspicuous by its absence but that's
not all remember Trump's deal with the
Taliban yeah the one about not turning
Afghanistan back into a nest of
terrorists well see for yourself
Afghanistan once again terrorist Safe
Haven as U.S Over the Horizon capability
faces limitations expert that's right
visualpolitik viewers groups like
Al-Qaeda and the Pakistani Taliban known
as the TDP now roam freely throughout
the country in fact do you know where
Al-Qaeda leader Ayman al-zawahiri was
assassinated in the summer of 2022. in
the very center of Campbell the Afghan
and capital Al Qaeda leader Iman
al-zawahiri killed the United States
says a CIA drone strike has killed Al
Qaeda leader Iman al-zawahiri in
Afghanistan's Capital Kabul in the
biggest blow to the group since its
founder Osama Bin Laden was killed in
2011. although it is true that the
Taliban are at least fighting the
Islamic State of corusa the organization
that bombed the Kabul Airport as ubesh
troops were withdrawing and killed a
dozen U.S soldiers and 150 Afghans but
let's be honest this confrontation has
nothing to do with the agreement with
Trump instead it has to do with the
hostilities that exist between the two
groups basically a good old Power
struggle yet despite all the atrocities
many analysts also say they are very
surprised by some aspects of the
taliban's economic management
you see after the initial economic shock
the Taliban have managed to handle and
stabilize the country's economy for
example they have managed to recover to
some extent the value that the national
currency The Afghani had before
International isolation by means of a
tighter control of the dollars leaving
the country what's more according to the
World Bank corruption in customs has
fallen from 62 to 8 due to the severe
punishments imposed by the Sharia or
Islamic law basically steal and we will
cut off your hand they've also raised
enough Revenue to be able to pay the
salaries of the country's 800 000 civil
servants including 150 000 soldiers and
two hundred thousand policemen
they are even allowing themselves the
luxury of launching some large projects
Taliban are digging an enormous Canal a
mega project in Northern Afghanistan
risks raising Regional tensions of
course all of this is just a side note
do you think that the situation of the
country allows us to be optimistic well
as you can imagine nothing could be
further from the truth
after the Taliban came to power the
country was totally isolated in addition
to suffering from a host of sanctions
between 2021 and 2022 the economy fell
by 35 taking hundreds of thousands of
jobs and destroying most of the
country's small productive fabric this
as you can imagine is pushing Afghan
Society to the Limit according to the UN
97 of the population lives in poverty
and the number of Afghans in need of
humanitarian Aid has risen from about 6
million in 2019 to 28 million today
basically this means that famine is
rapidly taking hold in Afghanistan and
this is despite the humanitarian Aid
sent by the UN the United States the
European Union and other International
Players naturally given such a scenario
it is not surprising that the Taliban
are quickly looking for a solution which
is primarily to try to be recognized at
the international level in order to
achieve some stability and normality but
do you think there is any state that
wants to recognize this regime well
let's take a look at that right now
recognition the great Taliban challenge
foreign
we've already told you that in the 1990s
only three countries recognized the
Taliban government well do you know how
many countries have recognized them in
this second period the total number is
zero zero countries indeed visual
politic viewers this time even Pakistan
itself has wanted to hold off
recognizing them for now and they have
been supporting them almost since the
beginning but this time things are
different nearly two years after
returning to power not even their
closest Partners trust them for instance
let's take the case of Pakistan Pakistan
has several problems with this
Afghanistan Taliban starting with the
support that India is giving them which
logically is not sitting well with
Islamabad even so it is probably the
Border conflict over the so-called
Durand Line that is generating the most
tension this line which separates the
two countries was established by the
British Empire in 1893 and since the
independence of both countries has been
a constant source of tension in fact
clashes between border troops from both
countries are not uncommon however
things appear to be calming down
Pakistan Afghanistan agreed to boost
trade lower border pensions even so
let's not go too fast there is one issue
that is not only an impediment to
Pakistan recognizing the Taliban but
also to two of the most important
Regional and Global players China and
Russia
[Music]
thank you
whether it is Pakistan China or Russia
all three countries have one thing in
common their concern for National and
Regional Security in this regard for
example Pakistan has accused the Afghan
Taliban of providing a safe haven to the
Pakistani Taliban who broke the
ceasefire of the Pakistani government on
the 28th of November 2022 and who have
already staged attacks in major cities
in the country such as Peshawar and
Karachi killing dozens of people for its
part China has a similar concern but in
this case with the East turkistan
Islamic movement which is formed by
Islamic fundamentalists of the uyghur
ethnic group that concentrates its
activity in the xinjiang autonomous
region which is right on the border with
Afghanistan in this way China fears that
the Taliban will make its country a safe
haven for the uyghur militants and
therefore demands that Kabul continue to
hand over those it captures as the
previous Afghan government had been
doing nevertheless the Taliban have
already released several of them which
has not gone down too well in Beijing
in this regard Russia is the least
concern of three countries as its
biggest threat the Islamic State of
coruscan which has begun an anti-russia
campaign is currently being fought by
the Taliban on Afghan soil yet Russia
has not yet recognized the Taliban as
the legitimate rulers of Afghanistan
either of course that does not mean that
it has not already approached them
[Music]
in fact Russia was the first state to
conclude such an agreement with the
Taliban Taliban signed deal with Russia
to buy cheap oil gas and wheat in
reality China is not lagging behind
either it has lifted 98 of tariffs on
Afghan products and has started giving
visas to Afghan businessmen and not only
that despite Afghanistan's poor
infrastructure last year it also
approved a 216 million dollar investment
to build an industrial park on the
outskirts of Kabul besides what can I
say if China Russia or Pakistan were to
recognize the Taliban government it
would not be a surprise and so they have
already taken some steps in that
direction that of recognizing the
Taliban of course without credible
guarantees of security and cooperation
this is also up in the air and the truth
is that it would not change anything
that much either
it would be a different story if the
United States or the European Union were
to recognize them and believe it or not
many U.S analysts are already asking for
it the reason well the usual one to be
able to influence to some extent the
drift of the Taliban government and the
country the United States should
diplomatically recognize Afghanistan's
Taliban government this is not easy for
me to say as a former Afghan Ambassador
doing so will be perceived as a painful
betrayal for many but the alternative
allowing Afghanistan's dangerous descent
into a Hermit Kingdom and forsaking the
insight and means to influence our shape
events would mean more dire consequences
for all javeed Ahmed former Afghan
Ambassador in a foreign policy article
2023 like this Ambassador many analysts
believe that neither sanctions nor any
other form of coercion is going to make
the Taliban relent in their efforts to
continue violating human rights and that
the best thing the United States can do
at this point is to recognize this
before any other country does in an
attempt to make Afghanistan a less
hostile place so there this is the
current debate
[Applause]
[Music]
in any case for this to happen there
would first have to be some certainty
that the Taliban would listen to U.S
recommendations something that let's not
kid ourselves seems highly unlikely so
far Biden has given no sign that he will
recognize the Taliban which is a blow to
an Afghanistan that is going through one
of its worst times in its history that
said the question is for all of you do
you think Biden should recognize the
Taliban could Trump do so if he returns
to the presidency in 2024 which states
do you think will be the first to
recognize them will Russia be the first
to form a Brotherhood of the Pariah
States you can leave me your answers in
the comments and as always don't forget
that here on visualpolitik we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
this channel hit the little bell so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like the video please like it and I will
see you in the next one all the best see
you soon
[Music]